Hallo, mein Name ist Mutlu Karakus. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Astetik. Heute bin ich für Sie zuständig.
So erst würde ich Ihnen das Eskieschip führen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, bin ich.
So erstell ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihren persönlichen Daten. Anschließend besprechen wir Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Peter Niehoff. Herr Niehoff, könnten Sie bitte Ihren Nachnamen und Vornahmen nachzumustabieren?
Der Nachname Niehoff, N-I-E-H-O-F-F, Niehoff. Niehoff, so wie immer. Wichtig?
Ja, N-I-E, N-I-E-H-O-F-F, Niehoff. Niehoff, Herr Niehoff, wie alt sind Sie und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin 57 Jahre alt und bin geboren am 20. August 1968.
1968. Wie schwer und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich wiege 88 kg und bin 1,82 m groß.
82 m groß. Wichtig?
Ja.
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen? Was für Beschwerden haben Sie?
Ich habe seit ca. 3 Stunden starke Schmerzen im Rücken und die Strahlen aus bis vorne in die Leiste.
Wo genau tut das?
Im Rücken, hinten an den unteren Rippen, da ist der Schmerz im Rücken.
Dann geht es runter bis unten in die Leiste rechts.
Wie schwer sind die Schmerzen?
Auf eine Schmerzskolour von 1 bis 10 vorbei 1, am wenigsten 10 unerträglich ist.
Ja, ich würde sagen 6 bis 8. Schmerz ist immer da und manchmal kommt aber so eine starke Welle des Schmerzes.
Und dann ist es 8 zwischen 6 und 8.
6 und 8. Könnten Sie diese Schmerzen aushalten oder brauchen Sie Schmerzmittel?
Wenn es jetzt nicht mehr so lange dauert, halte ich das aus.
Könnten Sie mir sagen, ob diese Beschwerden langsam auftreten oder plötzlich?
Ja, ich würde sagen innerhalb von 20 Minuten haben sie sich so aufgebaut.
Wie würden Sie diese Beschwerden Schmerzen beschreiben?
Da sind mehr so dumpf, aber wenn die Schmerzspitze kommt, kann der Schmerz auch sehr stechend sein.
Aber hauptsächlich dumpf.
Gibt es bestimmte Auslöser? Erinnern Sie sich daran?
Nein, ich habe keine Ahnung. So etwas habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Und Sie haben schon gesagt, diese Schmerzen sind immer da und manchmal besser und manchmal schlimmer.
Sie sind immer da, aber manchmal sehr stark.
Ist Ihnen übel oder müssten Sie erbrechen?
Mir ist übel und ich habe fast das Gefühl, dass ich auch erbrechen muss.
Bisher habe ich aber noch nicht erbrochen, aber mir ist übel.
Sie haben schon einiges beschwerden?
Nein.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ich glaube nicht.
Haben Sie Stulfrosk oder Nachtschweiß?
Nachtschweiß weiß ich nicht, weil es erst seit 3 Stunden angefangen hat.
Aber ich muss stark schwitzen.
Jetzt bin ich ziemlich verschwitzt.
Schüttelfrost habe ich nicht.
Stark schwitzen.
Beim Erzeichen haben Sie jetzt richtig stark schwitzen?
Ja, indem ich die Schmerzen habe.
Wie ist Ihr Apathet?
Normalerweise ist der gut, aber jetzt ist mir übel und jetzt kann ich nichts essen.
Jetzt habe ich auch keinen Hunger.
Normalerweise ist der Apathet gut.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Stuhlgang oder beim Wasserlassen?
Stuhlgang nicht, aber beim Wasserlassen habe ich bemerkt, ich war vorhin auf Toilette
und da hatte ich den Eindruck, dass der Urin ziemlich dunkel ist.
Es hat auch etwas geschmerzt beim Wasserlassen, es hat gebrannt.
Wie oft müssen Sie auf Toilette gehen?
Seitdem ich die Schmerzen habe, war ich nur einmal auf Toilette.
Einmal auf Toilette?
Haben Sie Blut im Urin bemerkt?
Nicht direkt, aber der Urin ist sehr dunkel.
Dunkel, so wie Cola.
Er ist mehr so dunkelbraun.
Wie ist der Schlaf?
Normalerweise ist der Schlaf gut.
Ich habe zwar in meiner Arbeit auch manchmal Nachtdienst machen,
aber ich habe auch Nachtdienst gemacht.
Ich habe auch Nachtdienst gemacht.
Ich habe zwar in meiner Arbeit auch manchmal Nachtdienst gemacht,
aber dann ist der Schlaf in diesen Tagen nicht so gut.
Nachtdienst?
Okay.
Im letzten Zeit haben Sie Angewicht verloren?
Nein.
Ich habe ein paar Fragen, so Ihre Vorgeschichte.
Leiden Sie an coronascheinstranken?
Ich habe hohen Blutdruck.
Seit zwei Jahren nehme ich ein Medikament.
Zwei Jahre, wichtig.
Ja, dann nehme ich ein Medikament.
Ja, ein Medikament der Früh.
Wie bitte?
Haben Sie Bluthoft oder seit zwei Jahren?
Seit zwei Jahren.
Seit zwei Jahren müssen Sie Medikamente einnehmen.
Ist Ihnen außer der Bluthoftdruck andere chronische Erbrankungen bekannt?
Ja, ich habe noch hohe Hansauerwerte.
Da hatte ich auch schon mal einen Gichtanfall.
Und da muss ich auch ein Medikament nehmen.
Schilddrüse?
Okay.
Schilddrüse unter Funktion?
Haben Sie Schilddrüse unter Funktion oder über Funktion?
Nein, ich hatte eine Operation an der Schilddrüse.
Da wurde ein Teil der Schilddrüse entfernt,
weil da zwei Knoten drin waren.
Und die mussten entfernt werden.
Die waren ziemlich groß.
Seitdem muss ich jeden Tag eine Tablette nehmen.
Okay.
Und wurden Sie noch operativ behandelt?
Operiert wurde ich einmal an der Schilddrüse.
Das war vor sechs Jahren.
Da wurde ein Teil der Schilddrüse entfernt.
Sechs Jahre.
Da habe ich noch eine Blinde am Obentfernen.
Ich habe noch eine Blinde am Obentfernen.
Ich habe noch eine Blinde am Obentfernen gehabt.
Im Alter von 14 Jahren.
Und es wurden auch meine Mandeln operiert.
Da war ich neun Jahre alt.
Mandeln.
Operationen mit neun Jahren.
Und Blinde am Operationen vor vier Jahren.
Ich verstehe richtig.
Die Blinde war mit 14 Jahren.
Im Alter von 14 Jahren.
Und die Schilddrüsen-Operation war vor sechs Jahren.
Und nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf Medikamente ein.
Ja, für den Blutdruck nehme ich ein Mittel ein.
Das habe ich hier auf dem Zettel.
Das heißt Rami-Pril.
Dann nehme ich zwei Tabletten pro Tag.
In welche Dosierung nehmen Sie ein?
Stärke, dahinter steht fünf.
Ja, Rami-Pril fünf.
Und dann nehme ich noch für die Harnsäure.
Auch ein Medikament ein.
Dann nehme ich eine halbe Tablette morgens.
Das heißt Allo Purinol.
Halbe Tablette nehmen Sie ein.
In welche Dosierung?
Ja, da steht 300 hinter.
Dann nehme ich noch ein für die Schilddrüse.
L-Tyroxin heißt das.
L-Tyroxin 75.
75.
Eine Tablette morgens.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie bei Bedarf Medikamente ein?
Nein.
Und sind bei Ihnen Allergien oder Unterreglichkeit bekannt?
Nein, ist mir nicht bekannt.
Gut.
Ich hätte ein paar Fragen.
Ihre Familien am Nässe.
Gibt es Ihnen Ihre Familie chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, mein Vater ist 81 Jahre alt.
81?
Ja, der ist vor vier Jahren an Darmkrebs operiert worden.
Ja, Darmkrebs-Operation.
Ja, und dann hat er noch Alteiszucker.
Und vor zehn Jahren wurde bei ihm ein schwarzer Hautkrebs operiert.
Vor zehn Jahren schwarze Hautkrebs-Operation.
Ja, meine Mutter, die ist 80 Jahre alt.
Die hat schwere Arthrose im linken Knie.
Schwere Arthrose, ja.
Und sie hat Schilddrüsen unter Funktion.
Schilddrüsen unter Funktion.
Ja, und dann habe ich noch eine Schwester, die ist 54 Jahre alt.
Die hatte vor einem Jahr Eierstockkrebs.
Eierstockkrebs.
Und vor fünf Jahren hatte sie einen schweren Verkehrsunfall.
Vor fünf Jahren hatte sie schwerer Unfall.
Ja, und da hatte sie einen Oberarmbuch rechts, dann eine Quetschung der Lunge.
Eine Quetschung.
Und da musste ihr die Milz entfernt werden, weil da hatte sie eine Blutung in der Milz.
Okay, Milz entfernt.
Und welche Lungen ist linksseitige, beiseitige?
Ich weiß es nicht mehr genau. Ich glaube, das war auf der rechten Seite.
Jedenfalls war sie längere Zeit auf der Intensivstation und musste auch beatmet werden.
Aber inzwischen geht es ihr eigentlich wieder ganz gut.
Ja, okay, Gott sei Dank.
Noch etwas gibt es zu anderen Personen.
Nein, sonst nicht.
Und ich würde einfach fragen, würde ihr eine Lebensgewohnheit stellen?
Darf ich wissen, ob Sie rauchen?
Nein, ich rauche nicht.
Okay, und zunehmen Sie Alkoholsussig?
Ja, aber nicht jeden Tag.
Ich trinke vielleicht Bier, vielleicht drei, vier Mal pro Woche eine Flasche.
Bier, drei pro Woche Flasche.
Hatten oder haben Sie Kontakt mit dem Zedroken?
Nein.
Okay, sind Sie vorstellig gegen?
Ja, da bin ich.
Da achtet der Betriebsarzt immer drauf.
Okay, waren Sie in Lesterseid im Ausland?
Ich war im letzten Sommer, August, da war ich in Griechenland.
Ja, zwei Wochen lang.
Aber das war mir zu heiß.
Das ist im Sommer für mich zu heiß.
Aber das war sonst gut, aber es war zu heiß.
Okay, gut unterhals ich weiß.
Und sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet und wohne mit meiner Frau zusammen.
Wir haben eine Tochter, 23 Jahre alt.
23 Jahre alt?
Ja, die hat von der Kindheit auf schon Zucker.
Zucker, Kindheit.
Und aber die wohnt nicht mehr bei uns, die studiert.
Studiert. Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Feuerwehrmann.
Feuerwehrmann.
Ist Ihnen beim Arbeiten Stress ausgesetzt?
Manchmal schon, wenn es Rettungseinsätze sind
oder Brandeinsätze, Verkehrsunfälle,
das ist manchmal schon ein starker Stress.
Ja, ich verstehe her.
Und Treiben, Sie sind Feuerwehrmann.
Und natürlich, Sie sollten Sport treiben.
Ja, ich versuche noch Sport zu treiben.
Jetzt fahre ich viel mit dem Fahrrad.
Manchmal jogge ich auch.
Aber es hängt immer davon ab, wie ich mit der Arbeitszeit,
mit der Arbeitsschicht zurechtkomme.
Okay.
Und ich möchte Ihren aktuellen Werte zurückkommen.
Ich möchte kurz zusammenfassen.
Und wenn ich etwas Fasch sage,
können Sie mit mir korrigieren.
Ja.
Sie haben seit dreistüchenden Rechtszeitungen
Rückenschmerzen mit Ausstrahlung in die linken Leiste.
Rechte Leiste.
Und die Rückenschmerzen sind rechts
und sie strahlen in die rechte Leiste.
Rechte Leiste.
Schmerzintensität wurde mit 6 bis 8 bewertet
und immer da, aber manchmal besser.
Manchmal erschlimmer geworden.
Sie haben früher nicht erliegelt Beschwerden gehabt.
Sie haben auch Ubelkeit, aber ohne Erbrechen.
Sie haben schon ein paar Veränderungen des Urins bemerkt.
Manchmal ist es brändig beim Wasserlassen.
Es ist ein Brennschmerz.
Und Sie haben keine bestimmte Auslöse bemerkt.
Wichtig.
Und haben Sie irgendeine Veränderung der Augen oder der Haut bemerkt?
Nein.
Wie sind Sie hier gekommen?
Ich bin mit dem Taxi gekommen.
In dieser Zeit haben Sie dagegen etwas eingenommen?
Nein, bis jetzt noch nicht.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Da haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Nein, Hauptsache, Sie können mir bald helfen mit den Schmerzen.
Aber Sie wollen mich ja erst gerade untersuchen.
Ja, ich werde Ihnen erst einmal eine Ausführliche,
körperliche Untersuchung durchführen
und Urin abnehmen.
Dann könnte ich Ihnen etwas genauer sagen
und über Ihren Beschwerden sprechen.
Okay, das können wir so machen.
Gut.
Ja, okay.
Und bitte nehmen Sie Platz.
Bitte legen Sie sich hier.
Und ich komme gleich.
Ja, okay, danke.
Ich bewege mich aber lieber etwas wegen der Schmerzen.
So richtig liegen kann ich nicht gut.
Ich muss mich immer etwas bewegen.
Das ist besser.
Okay.
Beim Bewegen verbessern die Schmerzen sich.
Ja, besser als liegen.
Liegen ist nicht gut.
Gut, dann haben Sie jetzt einige Minuten Zeit.
Und ich sehe schon im Chatverlauf gibt es hier schon lebhafte Informationen,
Vermutungen, Diagnosen.
Gibt es Fragen von den Kolleginnen und Kollegen?
Oder was würden Sie eventuell noch zusätzlich fragen?
Es ist ja schon, denke ich, das meiste gefragt worden.
Vielleicht noch eine Frage stellen nach einem Unfall.
Der Patient klagt ja über akute Beschwerden,
die eher vom Rücken ausgehen, zwar ausstrahlen,
aber ich würde immer die Frage stellen,
hatten Sie in letzter Zeit vielleicht einen Unfall,
einen Sturz oder so etwas?
Das würde ich zumindest fragen.
Nein, der Patient antworten Nein, habe ich nicht gehabt.
Ich habe keinen Sturz gehabt, keinen Unfall.
Und ich habe eine weitere Frage.
Ist Ihnen Gelenkschmerzen jetzt auch oder Veränderungen
der Gelenke bemerkt?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Gut, wenn jetzt die Kollegen keine weiteren Fragen mehr haben,
dann lassen wir jetzt den Kollegen etwas in Ruhe.
Ich kann inzwischen durch kurz hier meine Haut präsentieren.
Letzte Woche haben Sie die auch gesehen.
Jetzt trocknet es langsam hier alles ein, die Florestenzen.
Ich nehme seit vier Tagen keine Salve mehr.
Ich habe jetzt die Therapie beendet und jetzt langsam trocknet es ab.
Wahrscheinlich werden Sie nächste Woche nur noch
vielleicht ganz wenig Reste sehen auf der Haut.
Gut, wenn jetzt keine Fragen mehr sind,
dann lasse ich Sie jetzt etwas in Ruhe.
Fragen alle, was haben Sie getan,
als die Beschwerden begannen?
Sie meine die Tätigkeit, die ich gerade gemacht habe.
Das war keine körperliche Belastung.
Das war direkt nach dem Frühstück.
Ich habe gefrügstückt und danach fingen die Beschwerden an.
Aber ich habe da keine körperliche Belastung gemacht.
Gut, dann komme ich gleich wieder.
Guten Abend, Herr Oberarzt.
Hallo.
Haben Sie seit, ich habe einen neuen Patientin aufgenommen.
Ich möchte Ihnen vorstellen.
Ja, habe ich.
Es handelt sich um 57,
einen 57-jährigen Herrn Peter Niehoff,
der 88 kg schwer ist.
Und 1,82 m.
Prost.
Er schädelte sich heute bei uns wegen,
seit 3 Stunden plötzlich ein setzender,
dumpfartige, manchmal stehende, red-seitige Flankschmerzen
mit Ausstrahlung in rechten Leisten.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde 6 bis 8 bewertet.
Die Patienten hatten, dass die Schmerzen dauerhaft sind.
Jedoch manchmal besser, manchmal schlimmer werden.
Beim Bewegen besser sich die Schmerzen.
Auch dieser Patient klagte über 9 sehr ohne Emäßis.
Die vegetative Anämpfung ist unauffällig,
bis auf Duserie und Schmerzbedingte Inaphetenz.
Außerdem berichtete der Patient, dass der Urin dunkler geworden ist.
Und vor Erkrankungen leidet der Patient
die Arterielle Hypatonie seit 2 Jahren.
Und auch an der Gicht vor 6 Jahren.
Der Gicht zugrunde liegt eine Erhöhung einer
Hyperurikemie.
Er hatte eine Arthritis-Urika.
Und bei den Patienten würde eine Thereo-Depthemie durchgeführt.
Der Patient gab anders.
Er hatte 2 Knoten gehabt.
Er hatte eine Schilddrüse und wurde ziemlich groß.
Seine Schilddrüse?
Sie können sagen, dann würde sich übergehen in die Operation.
Dann können Sie vielleicht sagen, fangen Sie vielleicht mit den Operationen jetzt gerade an.
Dann kommen Sie auf die Schilddrüse als letzte Operation.
Was wurde bei den Patienten operiert?
Bei den Patienten wurde die Schilddrüse und die Appendoktomie operiert.
Wann war die Schilddrüse und die Appendoktomie?
Die Appendoktomie war im Alter von 40 Jahren.
14 Jahre.
Und die Transylaktomie war mit 9 Jahren.
Bezüglich der Schilddrüsen der Thereo-Depthomie, können Sie da noch etwas zu sagen?
Warum wurde die Thereo-Depthomie durchgeführt?
Der Patient erwähnte, dass er 2 große Knoten gehabt hat.
Und sein Schilddrüse ist ziemlich groß geworden.
Man kann sagen, aufgrund einer Struma nodosa,
wurde vor 6 Jahren eine wahrscheinlich hemi-thereodectomie oder subtotale Schilddrüsen-Resektion durchgeführt.
Etwas verbleibt ja immer noch an der Schilddrüse.
Nehmt der Patient Medikamente ein?
Ja, der Patient nimmt Ramipril, 5 Milligramm, 2 Tablette täglich und Allopryol, 300 Milligramm,
halbe Tablette, aber und Eldroxin, 75 Mikrogramm morgens.
Gut, das sind die Medikamente.
Gut, fahren Sie bitte fort.
Und in der Familienanähe leidet der Vater die arbeitische Medikamente zu weit.
Und auch bei dem Vater eine Kollektomie.
Was war die Diagnose bei dem Vater?
Darum Krebs.
Ein Kolonkarzinom?
Ja, Kolonkarzinom.
Wegen des Kolonkarzinoms eine Operation durchgepürt.
Ja, wurde wahrscheinlich eine Kolon-Teil-Resektion durchgeführt.
Was gab es noch an Operationen bei dem Vater oder Erkrankungen?
Die Arbeit ist meines Tipps zu weit und durch Malin-Mennonma,
wegen der Malin-Mennonma und wegen der Operationen durchgekürt.
Man kann sagen vor zehn Jahren wurde ein Malignis-Melanom
therapiert oder operiert.
Wir wissen das nicht so genau.
Der Patient weiß das vielleicht auch nicht so ganz genau, was da alles gemacht wurde.
Gut, das sind die und bei der Mutter?
Seine Mutter ist jetzt 80 Jahre alt.
Sie hat links Seite Konathros.
Bei der Mutter wurde eine auch Schildtryodoktemie durchgeführt.
Der Patient hat nur gesagt, meine Mutter leidet an einer Schilddrüsen-Unterfunktion.
Das heißt ja nicht, dass sie operiert worden ist.
Schilddrüsen-Unterfunktion wird ja auch medikamentös behandelt.
Kennen Sie den Fachbegriff für Schilddrüsen-Unterfunktion?
Hypotryose.
Was hat die Mutter denn noch?
Die Mutter ist jetzt ne, die Mutter haben wir alles durch.
Was gibt es Geschwister?
Der Patient hat eine Schwester, ist jetzt 54 Jahre alt.
Sie hat Ovarium-Karzinom.
Ovarial-Karzinom?
Ja, Karzinom seit 5 Jahren.
Vor einem Jahr?
Ja, einem Jahr.
Und was war es vor 5 Jahren?
Sie hatte einen schweren Unfall.
Und Rheumeros-Beruch.
Fraktur.
Und Milz-Zipillonektomie.
Zipillonektomie, ja, sehr gut.
Und auch Lungenkontizion.
Sehr gut, super.
Also die Patientin hatte wahrscheinlich vor 5 Jahren
einen Verkehrsunfall mit Politrauma.
Esplenectomie, Lungenkontizion und Hume-Ros-Fraktur.
Ja, okay.
Prima, was ist denn Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose?
Die anamnestischen Angaben deuten auf Amherstern
und Piole Nefritis hin.
Die Franziadeiagnostische,
Acute appendicitis,
auch Pancitis
und Wertqualitis.
Ja, gucken Sie mal in den Chat.
Da unten hat der Kollege Ratwas geschrieben.
Im Chat, können Sie das nicht sehen.
Eine Sache ist so, der Patient hat kein Fieber.
Ja, Fieber hat der Patient nicht.
Das würde ich die Piole Nefritis...
Ja, ja.
Rauschbeißen, er hat einen heftigen Schmerz,
ziemlich stark, der wellenförmig ist,
der Schmerz, mal 6, aber auch bis 8.
Da muss man eigentlich an einen Harnleiterstein
eventuell denken, oder einen Ureterstein.
Das spricht eher dafür.
Der Schmerz strahlt als Flankenschmerz in die Leiste,
vielleicht sogar in den Hoden ein, ins Krotum.
Also, ich würde da eher sagen, nicht die Piole Nefritis,
sondern würde eher sagen, ein wahrscheinlich Ureterkollig.
Das ist wahrscheinlich die Erstdiagnose.
Dieser kollegartige Schmerz, der Patient hat ja gesagt,
also 6 ist er mindestens, und manchmal ist er sogar bis 8.
Dann kommt so eine Kollig, eventuell.
Und ich habe es oft so erlebt, dass diese Patienten
lieber sich dann etwas bewegen, als wenn sie ruhig liegen.
Manche Patienten mit Bauchschmerzen,
mit Abdominalschmerzen, liegen ja lieber ruhig.
Und wollen sich nicht bewegen.
Bei Ureterkolligen kann es eher sein, dass die Leute versuchen,
eine bestimmte Position einzunehmen.
Ja, gut.
Trotzdem finde ich, haben sie das sehr gut gemacht.
Ich habe sie gut verstanden.
Sie haben das finde ich auch ziemlich gut systematisch gemacht.
Sie kennen viele Fachbegriffe.
Ja, finde ich auch sehr gut.
Es war jetzt ja auch für sie ein fachfremder Fall.
Ja, das ist so.
Und ich finde, das haben sie trotzdem gut gelöst.
Und wenn sie diese Ruhe beibehalten,
dann werden sie die Prüfung gut bestehen.
Sie haben das Angebot gemacht früh,
dass sie den Patienten Analgetika geben könnten.
Er hat gefragt, halten Sie das aus?
Ich fand das auch sehr gut.
Sie können natürlich die Prüfung,
Sie können natürlich den Schmerz noch etwas anders beschreiben.
Sie haben gesagt, der Patient berichtet über einen Flankenschmerz.
Das ist durchaus bedizinisch auch gut.
Man könnte auch sagen, der Patient beschreibt einen Dorsalenschmerz.
Rechts Dorsal, Höhe des Rippenbogens hinten unten.
Und strahlt aus in die Rechtsinguinal oder in die rechte Skrotum.
Das gibt es auch.
Differenzialdiagnostisch wird da gerade gefragt.
Ja, es kann natürlich eventuell auch eine geilen Blasenaffektion sein.
Eine Cholizistitis oder eine, da fehlt vielleicht das Fieber oder eine Kolik.
Das kann sicherlich auch rottisch spielen.
Auch, ja, die Pylonephritis würde ich vielleicht nicht so dran denken.
Aber natürlich muss man sie einbeziehen.
Aber sie würden bei diesem Patienten natürlich den Urin untersuchen.
Sie würden vielleicht jetzt auch als bald nach der körperlichen Untersuchung
eine Ultraschall machen.
Um zu sehen, ist vielleicht die Niere gestaut, die rechte Niere.
Das würden sie machen.
Andere Differenzialdiagnosen jetzt außer Galle.
Atypische Appendicitis muss man auch mit in Betracht ziehen.
Aber ich würde in erster Linie, wie gesagt, die Orita-Kolik.
Daran denken.
Der Patient hat auch erhöhte Harnsäure, zumindest in der Vorgeschichte.
Es kann ein Uratstein sein, was auch immer.
Oder Genisterstein.
Aber so wie das sich annäßt, würde ich als erstes an eine
Harnleiter oder Urita-Kolik denken.
Ja, gut.
Ja, erstmal vielen Dank.